face à la crise du coville 19
le gouvernement a dégainé les moyens xxl
pour essayer de sauver le tourisme c'est
bien normal
le secteur est de taille la france est
le pays où le plus visité au monde près
de 82 millions de touristes viennent
profiter de la tour eiffel de la côte
d'azur ou des alpes
chaque année en mai peu après le début
du déconfinement edouard philippe
annoncé donc un plan de 18 milliards
d'euros spécifique pour le tourisme un
plan très axé sur les entreprises les
plus fragiles type tpe pme ou un fonds
de solidarité qui est en fait une aide
jusqu'à 10000 euros pour ce type
d'entreprise est prolongé jusqu'à la fin
de l'année est étendue aux entreprises
ayant jusqu'à 20 salariés et 2 millions
de chiffre d'affaires
les fameux presse une garantie de l'état
ont été renforcées l'accès au chômage
partiel prolongé jusqu'à septembre
en plus d'encourager bien sûr les
français à passer leurs vacances sur le
territoire pour relancer l'économie
bref un bon paquet de mesures avec
toutefois des oubliés du secteur
les vacataires ou intermittent du
tourisme type hôtesses agents de
sécurité et cuisiniers qui ont
d'ailleurs manifesté à paris début juin
pour tenter d'attirer l'attention du
gouvernement sur cette malheureuse
négligence